July 13 2019.
scientist Roy funch is journeying to
Northern Brazil
he's here to investigate something
bizarre revealed from space
you can't let an opportunity
like this past to see something that's
never been seen in a very real sense
High over the forests of the kachinga
region
the goi1 satellite captures an expanse
of barren soil recently cleared by
Ranchers
you see a semi-arid landscape with some
kind of pockmarks almost looks to me
like it could have been bomb craters or
some type of holes in the ground
analysts count more than 300 circles
across two patches of scrub
but zooming in reveals they aren't holes
at all
it looks like they're not depressions
but are raised areas mounds of some sort
when I look at the image the idea that
these structures could be some type of
burial mounds is plausible
giant burial mounds have been discovered
elsewhere in the Amazon dating back as
far as 6 000 years ago
if the satellite has revealed an
Undiscovered ancient burial site then
its scale is unparalleled
vast the possibility that they could be
burial mounds is amazing
funch is skeptical of the burial mound
Theory
there's too many of them you know the
the burial mounds are usually reserved
for you know Chiefs and high priests and
rich people
yet what they are is hard to tell
there's nothing like this in the world
that I know of and I've never heard
anything about them
the Mounds sit in a 386 thousand square
mile Wilderness known as the white
forest
which is a dry land
thorny deciduous vegetation that's
really totally intertwined you can't see
more than 20 30 feet in
okay this should be the stop
foreign
[Music]
led by the image coordinates funched
treks West
seeking signs of the Mounds among the
thorns and scrub
[Music]
thank you
really hot it gets sweltering here it's
in the 90s already here but it'll get to
a hundred
quite easily
[Applause]
I think we're getting near the mound
Fields I saw in the uh
satellite images this is this is where
they are
oh wow there we go there we go
Mounds
wow
oh boy
look at that
[Music]
magnificent
these are are not burial bounds
look how tall they are how evenly spaced
they are
it's just another world
the site in the satellite image funch
doubts these are man-made
nor does he believe they are a naturally
occurring feature of the landscape
it's just actually inconceivable that
there'd be a purely
geological origin the two symmetrical
they're too even
they're too well spaced for me they're
pretty obviously biogenic almost
certainly built by some sort of a
creature
funch has suspicions about which
I'm more pushed toward it being a
termite Mound than any other animal that
I can think of
termites are famous for some of their
huge structures in Africa and Australia
you get huge termite Mounds very complex
structures taller than this
but these structures look very different
from termite Mounds found elsewhere in
the world
and as funch explores further
cover a wider area than he ever imagined
okay you can see there's a mound over
there it's quite camouflaged one two
third one over there
there's no reason why they shouldn't
keep on going
as far as this goes on and on
[Music]
returning to the satellite image funch
makes a staggering discovery
not hundreds of Mounds not even
thousands
but Millions
200 million Mounds stretching through
the white forest for ninety thousand
square miles
zoom out a little bit you can see the
huge scale that we're talking about
more than the state of Michigan
it's unbelievable
if this is the work of termites it's
easily the largest Colony on Earth
but what baffles funch is that this land
appears to be lifeless
I don't see any termite activity I
haven't seen a lizard or snake or an ant
or anything crawling around here but
this is the kind of environment that you
just don't want to be active during the
day
to learn more funch waits for dusk
[Music]
at night the white forest is a hunting
ground for various wild animals
but funch's prey is smaller
now you have to be
quiet when you're looking for termites
to have tread softly because they're
very sensitive to vibrations on the
ground
[Music]
there's the guys
something around here
termites are Earth's great survivors
they were here before the dinosaurs 250
million years ago
see the guy popping in and out
but there's no building activity
this seems to be a foraging party rather
than a construction team
that's the leaf they chewed on
they probably have Chambers where they
with a store there's food for future
after several hours observing in the
dark funch is no closer to understanding
the hills seen from space
[Music]
the only way we'll ever know that is if
we come at it during the day
dig them up
yeah
termite Mounds are normally riddled with
ventilation shafts leading to numerous
Chambers
at the very heart sits the Royal chamber
here resides the queen
one of the most extraordinary females in
all nature she can lay 25 eggs a minute
for up to 50 years time enough to have a
family of 250 million
okay
is is this is pure clay
this is what's under the mount
but they've hit plain dirt
we've dug into what appears to be a
mound of dirt
all right this is they're not living
here
foreign